zach frank nehemiah
congratulations you've made it into the
final round of competition
now we're sending you back to your home
for just for five days
to recreate an iconic weapon from
history
and zap zap yes all right blade smith
good luck we'll see you in five days
let's do this huh
today we're here in sonora california
here to make an in zappa zap
let's see how this goes i can't fit it
in here
so i might have to do this thing
old-fashioned to be truthfully honest
i'm scared
my master had a personal emergency he
had to leave the competition
and now i'm stranded here doing this on
my own just got to keep it together
it's amazing i made it this far by
myself but
i'm going to give it my all give 110 see
what i can do
there we go today it's my turn
i gotta turn this square piece of hot
metal into blade
neon i have split it down the middle the
night before so that i can pull that
apart and there's my blade
zach better be bringing his game
[Music]
the charcoal forge is one of the most
interesting
ways to heat treat and what i'm looking
for is an even red
color all the way across that's sort of
coloring am i yep
let's hear how this thing sounds
[Music]
awesome it's hard
incredible day three
and i'd like to be a little further than
i am
i want this thing to be perfect before i
quench
i'm going to heat up my oil a little bit
here i want to be a foraging fire
champion i got to pull out all the
tricks
i figure i got to pre-heat this stuff if
you want to have it around 200 degrees
never had that going on it's
really getting a little bit out of hand
kind of getting to an uncontrollable
fire
i'm a little nervous i have never felt
anxiety like
this before really getting a little bit
out of hand
i need that stop sign kind of get into
an uncontrollable fire
luckily that worked i didn't want to
have the fire department out here
now i can quench my blade
today's my last day working this copper
cap
i've got to get this on here for part of
the decoration
all right oh damn it
crack i think i'm gonna just go right to
the grinder and grind it now
yeah the breaking of the handle is a
little bit of a blessing in disguise
now i can hang on to it right out to the
butt the handle is way too thick
yay i'm glad to be done neal and i'll
have it tomorrow
he will be sharpening the blade and
getting that completely finished
mr deville i'm ready for my close-up
my quench came out great i don't want to
be cocky or anything but the blade's
looking awesome
it's got all the intricate artwork on
the steel i really did a weird hammer
pattern so it looks like it was made of
just rocks in the congo
i'm hoping to put this in zappazap on
the mappa map
first time using it
i think it'll cut probably will kill
please miss now the zap zap was a brutal
weapon used in close quarter
we'll see how lethal your weapon is when
i deliver multiple strikes on this big
carcass
zac you're first you ready hell yeah
let's do this
[Music]
well zach that's a hog this is a hog
it is heavy but it's powerful the curve
you have in here digs
deep into the chops here it lacerates
the spine easily
overall your weapon will kill
frank nina maya your turn you ready
let's do this
frank nemaya it's light so i can go
hog wild on this carcass when you
dig in it cuts into the spine and into
the ribs
and lacerates quite well your zap
will kill the pig that zach's weapon hit
might have opened up a little bit more
but the truth is the wounds were just as
deep and just as bad
next up is the strength test
occasionally the nasapa zap was also
thrown
so to test the strength and durability
of weapons i'm going to throw them
into this wooden target three times zach
you're up you ready be gentle
i'm never gentle
nice
all right zach it's still tight nothing
loosened up
but right here there's a section that
blade that's just
not as sharp as the rest of it there's a
roll to that edge
that's pretty much right where it dug in
to the wall
frank nehemiah you're up next leon
[Music]
hmm
you can see right here the handle hit
the target in its rotation
but nothing's wrong with this blade
and held up nicely done guys thank you
thank you
anybody who actually has thrown weapons
you know
that the handles are disposable but did
metal
no the metal is designed to not take the
damage
next up the sharpness test we're gonna
see how well those blade edges held up
i'm gonna cut each one of these ropes
the meat will drop and a cut in each one
of those pieces of meat
zach you're up first you ready yes sir
okay
i do feel like me and frank nehemiah are
all neck and neck
it's definitely a tight race right now
i've never known what weakened the knees
means before but
actually my knees almost hurt
all right zach though your blade is
sharp
in most places that roll you picked up
i think that's what stopped it from
going through the rope immediately
but the second cut i caught it down in
here somewhere
and it just went right through all in
all that's a cutter
thank you frank nehemiah
[Music]
leon
[Music]
for cutting rope right off this divot in
the middle here
actually worked very well the handle
where it broke on the throw
didn't bother me at all it's below where
my hand sits
it's a cutter nicely done
bladesmiths what started out as a
competition focused on masters and
apprentices working together
turned into an apprentice going against
a master and a student
you rolled with it and here we are the
judges have made their final decision
and the master and apprentice forged in
fire champion title goes to
frank and nehemiah congratulations you
are the forged and fire master and
apprentice champions good job
zack unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut
zach first let me commend you for just
pushing through this solo
thank you sir you gave us a lot of
artistry in the forging of your blade
and that's very impressive for an
apprentice but that role you picked up
in the strength test
combined with that extreme weight of
that piece made it
very hard to wield and that's why we're
letting you go
understandable zach you got the heart of
a lion brother
but at this time i have to ask you to
please surrender your weapon
right now i'm pretty bummed but jesse
ought to be proud that i persevered and
stuck through this
hell i made it this far and i feel like
i did pretty good
i'm a winner in my own heart
frank nehemiah congratulations you are
the master and apprentice forged and
fired champions
good job that title also comes with a
check
for ten thousand dollars all right
gentlemen please present your weapon to
the judges
we won hey we're the first master in
apprentice champions
i am extremely proud of nehemiah him and
i sharing this
that's what i really do this for i think
to the zappos app that we
is that i think that the zapzap
represents exactly
us and that's why i'm very happy and
very proud
you